one fire
excuse me thank you
you're looking at the most powerful
rocket in the world NASA's so-called
space launch system for SLS it could
also be considered the biggest
flamethrower in the world
this puppy puts out 3.6 million pounds
of thrust and measures half a football
field long American football of course
and on Tuesday NASA will put the rocket
to one of its final tests running
through everything from avionics to
navigation to performance at colder
temperatures here's the thing if humans
are going to get their boots on Mars
they're going to need an ultra powerful
rocket like this so if it all goes well
the SLS will fire a spacecraft 40,000
miles past the moon in 2018 though this
will be an unmanned mission it'll be the
farthest a spacecraft built for humans
has ever traveled from Earth and that's
a big step to getting people to Mars one
day sure Mars is millions upon millions
of miles away not 40,000 but hey baby
steps